.
>> T YOUO CH.
>> JOI N IS
INCT SPEAL
WORKING VACCINE BOSN
CHILDREN'S HOITHE PRDMENK US E .
I WANT TOTHE FACT THA A S PRESIT
WHATOE LOOK>>,ALL,EEP OF
EVERY AMERICAN TO GET TO SOMEB
ALCY. VERYND SAID THE VIRUSEROFE
PEOPLE OUT ER TOO SOON OR
WITHOUT CAREFUL CONRATION TOW Y
THAT COULDOTENTIALLY>> A- WWE B.
DOING FASCINATING WORKND DOING
FORPEOPLEORASICALCHILDREN, FROWE
LL YOU'REOKING TO TELDERLY, BECO
CORONAVIRUS.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.CIELOPMET LT
CHARACTERISTICS OF WHO GIVE TO,A
BIOWESPOND T AVA VACCI DEVELOPME
PROG --
TITUTE
TAKING DIFNT APPROAWE'REESIGN PS
EARLY. BIO  O BLOODHAT B BY ELDW
AB OUTSIDEE BODY
ERENT CANDIDATEAC
SE WORT THATEE IS DIFFERE SEVER
ELRL A
YOU THOSE WHITELOOOU RESEARCH
WHATOU ABOUT
SOMETHING DR.
HE VACUL FOR PUBLICOLOU T 18MON?
UTLY. KNOW, WE'RE V GRATE
FAUCI'SEARS HIS
FASHION INSTITUTE O A
INIO DISEASESCH IS A MAJOR SUPP
OUR SEVEN.NO EVERYBODY AT  AND
THE U.S. IS WORKITHIS.
ALLO AECTIVE VACCI SOON AS
AC
YESTER FACT OF THE MATTER IS IFA
TS LIKE- WISH WE COUE ITTPER TA
YEARS.
WE THAT KINF ARE
BASICALLY BA
MOST-EDGE
HAVING EC OFLLABORATION BETWEEN.
>> I WAN T YOU
HOWON KE
JU D THIS HASOO INJU PEOPLET HO
WOND WHYS IAKE S>>GHT. TO REMBE
TI S SEVERALOUANTIBODIES AGAINSS
AIGGHKE PROTEN
MANY VIEWE SEENHAVIRU
WHTHE
TEIN ANTIGEN
ANTIBODIES AGAINST TK THETY VIR
FROM HUMAN
ALAVET
OAV
COMPONENMMUNE RESPO
LIKE R ME UP
MINE RESPONSH
STRONGER.
THAT MIGHT BE.AV VACCINE THAT'S
MIILLIONS EVEDOSE
THAT'S L.NLLOWS TO U  ANDN T YOT
RESPOND B THEVACCINE.
THEOASLONGER.O AN
AI C SE REASONS WE THINK
ADDING ANN
PO PART OF THEOLUTION AN EFFECT.
S THAT ANTIG H
DIFFERENT EFFECEP
THE AGE OF THE WRECCINEROT IN TT
ESPECIALLYELDEKIH AND TAKING US